[Music]
Khloe Kardashian gets real about the
struggles of motherhood and love who
pretty girl over the weekend the 34 year
old mom revealed that she had to stop
breastfeeding her two-year-old daughter
true Thompson in a series of tweets with
fan o my house my happy turn it all
started when one fan asked if she used a
breast pump at work to which Koko
replied I had to stop breastfeeding it
was really hard for me to stop
emotionally but it wasn't working from
my body
sadly and when fans started giving her
tip The Revenge body star tweeted I
tried every trick in the book water
special cookies power pumping massages
etc looking like a little lady
finally after one social media follower
offered her support Khloe admitted she
did feel a sense of release writing any
sec I had of downtime they was stressing
to produce more for the next feeding but
she said the hardest thing was how
different her sister Courtney's
experience was from her own Khloe
tweeted it was so frustrating because
for Kourt it was so easy for her to
breast feed but nursing isn't the only
thing clothes been stressing about last
week she opened up to social media
followers about having to leave true to
go back to work I have like missed a
feeding here they're the true but I've
never missed multiple feedings in a day
so I have a ton of anxiety